[Música]
[Aplausos]
fijaos en el cuadro que va a salir aquí
en la pantalla un pájaro no
pues no es mucho más que eso en realidad
os voy a demostrar que cualquier obra de
arte es mucho más de lo que parece si
sabemos mirar la podemos conseguir ser
personas
poco menos estresadas podemos conseguir
incluso ser más optimistas que para los
que somos pesimistas os garantizo que es
es un balde su peso en oro e incluso
podemos llegar a ser más listos
todo eso con un método que me he
inventado que he llamado método art
bulnes que es una mezcla de arte y
mindfulness el arte me viene de mi
trabajo me dedico a contar cuadros y
esculturas fotografías en medios de
comunicación y el mindfulness me llegó a
raíz de una depresión larga dura en la
que tuve que echar mano de psiquiatras
psicólogos y de meditación y mindfulness
y aquí me di cuenta de que las claves
que te dan estas terapias para llevar un
poco mejor tu vida están todas en el
arte y sin embargo nadie analiza las
obras desde este punto de vista
yo he desgranado todas estas claves en
este método que consiste en tres pasos
el primero de todos aprender a relajarse
mirando cuadros
concretamente mirando pinturas de
paisaje
la próxima vez que vayáis un museo
fijaros de que la inmensa mayoría de
obras de arte tienen un paisaje da igual
el tema que sea lo llevan por ejemplo
las pinturas religiosas ya sean alegres
como un nazi como el nacimiento o
tristes como la crucifixión de fondo
llevar un paisaje incluso los retratos
que suelen ser en habitaciones cerradas
el interior los pintores se buscan la
forma de incluir una ventana para que se
vea un paisaje de fondo porque porque
ellos saben que la visión de la
naturaleza nos predispone positivamente
hacia lo que vemos nos relaja y claro lo
que quieren es que nos guste su obra
para que se la compremos así que se las
agencian como sea para meternos un
paisaje hay que fijarse en los paisajes
en tres elementos fundamentales el
primero de ellos es el horizonte
nos relaja el horizonte porque nos
obliga a mirar el punto más lejano de la
escena pero al mismo tiempo nos invita a
meternos más allá a ir a explorar lo que
hay ese mundo desconocido que es un
mundo infinito inmenso donde somos
totalmente libres y la libertad relaja
bastante el siguiente elemento que hay
que mirar es son las nubes las nubes son
suaves blanditas cambian de forma y
aunque éstas están pintadas nada más
mirarlas inmediatamente nos empezamos a
imaginar cómo se mueven y se mueven muy
despacio y nos contagian ese ritmo lento
que tiene la pintura y tercer elemento
la luz la luz es lo más importante
porque es lo que le da el alma el
espíritu el sentimiento a los cuadros
pero además los pintores la utilizan
para movernos meternos por los cuadros
por ejemplo te llevan desde la parte más
luminosa del fondo la más alegre hasta
la parte más oscura que hay aquí en este
bosque por ejemplo más meditativa y
luego nos vuelven a llevar a la parte
más optimista y otra vez de vuelta y en
ese vaivén ese cambio de sentimientos
hace que nos abstraigamos de la realidad
y nos relajemos
así que la próxima vez que estéis tensos
con ansiedad estresados os sentáis
delante del ordenador elegir un cuadro
cualquiera el que sea y empezáis a
buscar estos tres elementos el horizonte
a lo lejos que te da la libertad de la
amplitud total las nubes que se mueven
despacito y te van llevando en este caso
de esa parte tormentosa al fondo más
estéreo más luminoso y la luz que te va
trasladando de la alegría del fondo a la
tormenta del primer plano y te vuelve a
llevar y así meciendo es poco a poco os
conseguiréis relajar
pues bien ya hemos llegado al primer
punto relajados una vez que hemos
conseguido esto segundo nivel vivir el
presente el aquí y el ahora
los artistas son los grandes maestros de
hacer eso fijaos el 80% de los
pensamientos que tenemos a lo largo del
día son o bien para dar vueltas a cosas
del pasado o a darle vueltas a cosas que
todavía no han ocurrido del futuro o
bien estamos pensando en la broca que
les ha echado el jefe lo mal que me ha
salido esto estamos ahí o bien le
estamos dando vueltas a la lista de la
compra que tenemos que hacer esta tarde
oa dónde vamos a ir mañana domingo o la
semana que viene a pasar las vacaciones
o lo que sea y mientras estamos rumiando
todo esto dándole vueltas no nos fijamos
en lo que tenemos alrededor no nos damos
cuenta revivir el aquí y el ahora no
miramos las cosas los artistas lo hacen
porque no les queda más remedio para
pintar un cuadro que observar
detenidamente todo lo que les rodea un
ejemplo
monet los nenúfares de monet al final de
su vida él estaba enfermo no se podía
mover de casa así que no le quedó más
remedio que fijarse en lo que tenía más
a mano que eran los nenúfares de su
jardín
se obsesiona con intentar captar como
las diferentes tonalidades de la luz de
la mañana a mediodía de la tarde y van
afectando y cambiando el color de estas
plantas en lugar de amargarse por todas
las cosas del pasado que ya no podía
hacer o torturarse pensando que le
quedaba poco futuro porque estaba muy
enfermo se dedicó a disfrutar de lo que
tenía más cerca desde luego el dolor de
su enfermedad no fue menos no mejoró
pero al menos consiguió
y disfrutar un poco más el aquí y el
ahora el poco tiempo que le quedaba
otro artista que se obsesionó con una
cosa muy sencilla fue van gogh ay le dio
por pintar los zapatos de la gente que
conocía ya base de mirar un objeto tan
simple que minusvaloramos tanto se dio
cuenta de que en realidad es fundamental
porque si es cuero cosido en una goma
pegado pero al mismo tiempo si te fijas
bien nos cambia la vida porque los
zapatos nos permiten salir a la calle e
ir a trabajar irnos de vacaciones
explorar el mundo subir al monte sin
ellos no podríamos hacer lo que está
haciendo aquí van gogh a base de
analizar lo que tiene delante las cosas
más pequeñas las valora más y cuando
valoras algo más
disfrutas más de lo que tienes y dejas
de darle vueltas a lo que no has
conseguido a lo que has perdido a lo que
quieres
eres más optimista como os prometía al
principio y esto no solamente puede
aplicarse con objetos se puede aplicar
también con personas
rembrandt lo hizo con su mujer la pintó
de todos los estados de ánimo posibles
alegre triste enfadada
yo tengo la teoría es muy personal de
que no la pintaba mucho porque la
quisiera mucho es exactamente al revés
la quería mucho porque la pintaba mucho
porque a base de analizar la más
insignificante movimiento en su mirada
más mínimo cambio de gesto se daba
cuenta de que eso se reflejaba en su
interior veía que tenía un la
personalidad compleja
miraba a su mujer como nosotros no sé si
os acordáis mirábamos a la chico el
chico que nos gustaba en el colegio que
cualquier cosa que hiciera nos parecía
maravillosa
pues el mantuvo esta actitud durante su
vida adulta con su mujer y cuando haces
esto con la gente que te rodea cuando la
valora es más la convivencia es mucho
mejor eres más optimista la vida te va a
ir no sé si mucho mejor pero al menos un
poco mejor
así que ya hemos llegado al segundo
nivel una vez que estamos relajados una
vez que ya hemos aprendido a vivir el
aquí y el ahora es por lo tanto ser más
positivos llega el tercer punto que es
aprender a pensar más allá no quedarnos
solamente con lo evidente con lo que
vemos sino fijarnos en lo que se esconde
detrás en un significado más allá de las
cosas
los artistas son los maestros de hacer
esto porque no hay ni un pintor ni un
artista que se dedique a pintar algo que
no signifique algo más de lo que parece
por ejemplo los nenúfares de monet
simbolizan el miedo a la muerte la
fragilidad de la vida
o por ejemplo los zapatos de van gogh
simbolizan para él la dignidad de los
simples no representan a todos aquellos
que alguna vez nos hemos sentido
insignificantes en esta enorme
maquinaria de la sociedad que creemos
que nos servimos para nada bueno si como
estos zapatos no somos tampoco gran cosa
somos un poco simples pero igual que
estos zapatos por lo menos para una
persona para alguien somos fundamentales
somos importantes
os acordáis del pájaro del que os
hablaba al principio bueno yo durante
años
veía este cuadro y pensaba que es un
pájaro bonito punto algo
atractivo de ver sin embargo empezando a
aplicar el método ar funes me di cuenta
de que claro si miras con detenimiento
lo que tienes delante
veis que tiene atada a la pata una
cadena
no es el cuadro de un pájaro bonito en
realidad es el retrato del dolor del
sufrimiento de un pájaro que no puede
volar pero es que si vais al punto 3 del
método y empezáis a pensar más allá de
lo evidente y os preguntáis qué es lo
que quería contar el artista con este
cuadro porque un pájaro atado a la pared
y veis que si está encadenado pero está
pasando orgulloso de sí mismo con
dignidad verdad en realidad lo que el
artista está pintando aquí es un retrato
de alguien que sufre puede que está
encadenado pero no pierde su orgullo su
dignidad en cara a los problemas con una
buena actitud así que algo que era muy
simple se ha convertido en un
significado muchísimo más complejo en
algo que nos inspira y en realidad de
este método arzones y el arte en general
el objetivo que tiene es inspirarnos en
nuestro día a día tanto lo bueno como en
lo malo para conseguir que nos demos
cuenta y disfrutemos las cosas buenas
pero sobre todo
acompañarnos en todas las cosas malas
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]